The method would look like river.replace and the first argument would be i and
the second one would be x, the return value would be Mxssxssxppx. Let's look at
the javadoc to see why. To find the javadoc for the string class we'll search,
and I'm just doing this in Google. So, I'm in the documentation for the string
class. You want to scroll down and look for the Method Summaries. Under the
method summaries, there are a couple of different options for replace. Let's
look at this one. It has a detailed description here, it takes a target and
replacement. The target is the things that we want to replace, and the
replacement is what we should replace them with. So in our case, the target
would be i in quotation marks, and the replacement would be x in quotation
marks. We can demo how this works in BlueJ. On the river string, I call replace
and I replace i with x. [SOUND], and we got what we expected.